foreign
some new footage for the new Ant-Man
film this TV spot starts off with Scott
Lang coming into the quantum realm now
it looks like the majority of this film
would take place in the quantum realm I
gotta say the CGI regarding the Clinton
realm is either hit or miss in some
scenes it looks really really good in
some other scenes not so much so we have
a new dialogue line here which I'll play
for you now this place that changes you
it means a Monster who thinks he's a God
and will this we have new footage of
Kang here with his suit being summer
onto him and I gotta say this scene
looks extremely badass I love everything
they're doing with Kang so far in this
film and while we're on the topic of the
main man Kang we have some footage of
the wasp and Ant-Man fighting him and I
gotta say this looks extremely badass we
also have scenes of Ant-Man and Cassie
running through with explosions going on
all around them in front of them to the
side it looks like a really good action
piece of the scene and to end off the
trailer we have a montage here of some
action scene the first off we have the
WASP ask and Ant-Man you ready to which
he responds with ready we then scenes of
Kang and then the WASP flying but real
money shot his Airmen going in for a
slam here against something that looks
like a force field now I imagine all
these action scenes here would take
place in the third Act of the film and
one large big battle and to end off the
trailer with some comedy a little
exchange between Ant-Man and his
daughter Cassie which I'll just play for
you guys now momentum right jump tap you
see what I did no you're like this small
and that wraps up everything for this
video guys let me know what you think in
the comment section below are you guys
excited for Ant-Man and the WASP points
of mania if you are please like the
video and I'll catch you in the next one